[? YOSSI FARJOUN: ?] This is
[? Doctor ?] MATLAB, Lecture 4,
Plotting.
MATLAB is a great
tool for making plots.
You can plot your data.
You can plot your results.
You can make very
elaborate plots.
But first, we need to learn
how to make simple plots.
So let's start
with a simple plot.
Let's plot sine on several
points between 0 and 2 pi.
So here we go, I've
made the points.
I put x versus sine of x.
I'm going to dock this figure.
Great, so here is
x versus sine x.
I can do x versus cosine x.
I can always also plot
sine x versus cosine x.
So the x is the sine,
and the y is the cosine.
And there it is.
It's supposed to be a circle.
It looks like an
ellipse, but notice
it goes from minus 1 to
1, and from minus 1 to 1.
So if you want to make
it look like a circle,
you can issue the
command axis square.
That looks like a circle.
But what if you wan
it to be red circle?
Then you can add
the line style, r.
You still have to tell
it it to be square.
You can put more than one
command, more than one plot
on one figure.
So you can do the
following, hold,
so now it's going to be held.
Hold toggles it.
If you hold again,
it will be off.
So I'm going to hold,
or you can say hold on,
and that will definitely be on.
And now, I want to plot, not x,
but I want 3 times x, and not x
here, but 5 times x.
And I want it to be black.
So here's my [INAUDIBLE]
figure on top of the circle.
I've already shown you
how to change color.
There's a few things
you can change.
If you look at the
plot help file,
you will see there is
a lot of information.
But here's the information
that I need for this.
These are the letters
for the colors.
These are the letters for the
markers I'll show you in a sec.
And these are the symbols
for the line style.
So let's see how that
makes a difference.
First I'll turn off the hold.
So here, I've
turned off the hold.
And now I'm going to plot this
with this type line style.
So that's the dotted line style.
And the markers going to be
this right-pointing triangle.
I can also change
the line width.
There's a typo.
There we go.
That makes it a little
bit difficult to see,
so let's make a
smaller line width.
There we go.
That's a nice, thick
line, if we need such.
You can also just change
the marker size, if we need,
without changing the line width.
You can have a title.
We can add an x
label and a y label.
And we can change the axis.
We can change the axis by
using the magnifying glass.
That was a double click to
go back to the original view.
Or I could change it directly
from the command line
by setting what I
want the axis to be.
So let's zoom into the
first quadrant, x, x, y, y.
There's the first quadrant, see?
From 0 to 1, from 0 to--
this is the first quadrant.
I can work with multiple
figures if I undock
and close this windows.
And what I'll do, is I'll
make my MATLAB window small,
so you can see where
the figures are.
Here we go.
So here is the undocked figure.
I can work with
multiple figures.
I can open another figure,
so here is another figure.
So I have Figure 1 and Figure 2.
And I can access them by
either clicking on them
before I issue my plot command,
or from the command line,
figure 2 will pop up Figure 2.
And now, if I plot something,
plot sine x cosine x in green,
then it will plot
it to this one.
I can change the
location of these plots
by looking at the following.
So this tells me
where this plot is.
This is the starting x,
starting y, width, and height.
And I can change all of these
by setting the position.
So instead of what it is,
let's set it to something else.
So now it became
this small thing.
Let's bring it up a bit,
so that you can see it too.
There we go.
I can add text to my figure.
I have to say what the x
is, 0, what the y is, 0,
and then what the text is.
So that puts it at this point.
0, 0 is the beginning
of the text.
I can clear the figure,
without closing it.
I can separate it into subplots.
Let's say, one row of
plots, two columns of plots.
Here's the first plot.
And in this first plot,
I'm going to plot this one.
And then the second plot,
I will plot this one.
Oh, that's a bit messy.
Let me make this bigger, so
you can see what's going on.
There you go, so
here is a subplot.
This is the first subplot.
This is the second subplot.
So, I encourage you
to read the help files
on all of the commands
that you saw here today,
as a way to learn how to
deal with plotting in MATLAB.